even if we look at the science of it
it's always going to be difficult to
raise a child that isn't biologically
yours I mean I'm adopted and I know a
fair amount about adoption statistics
and adopted kids are the hardest kids to
raise because of that dynamic because
even when you're adopted very young I
mean I was adopted at 9 months old even
baby's younger than me taken from birth
the biology isn't there it's the same
reason if you have a surrogate mother um
that baby has only known the woman it's
been inside even though biologically
it's the same as the other mother it's
only been inside this one woman so then
when you change that up it it does
change the dynamic and it makes it
difficult